hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 14 of my road to one bill series
uh we're starting the episode off with
some barrows uh we didn't get a very
good reward there but we're going to
grind out some barrows and then uh work
on some other money-making methods I
believe uh yeah let's get started all
right so we have another bars chest
coming up here and O this is
awkward I like 100% sure I killed that
person but yeah okay we'll kill this all
right we killed them and a pretty shitty
reward well got some runes at least and
another barrows chest gets another
pretty shitty reward another barrows
chest and that's still not that great
not even that many runes to be honest
and another be chest and another
mediocre Ward that is Barrow's chest
17 but we're not really do any luck to
be honest I believe this is Barrow's
chest number 18 and uh we got Loop half
that's pretty decent probably our best
reward in a little while to be honest
okay this is chest number 19 and uh we
got actually quite a bit of runes uh we
almost died to a rat though and chest
number 20 is a bunch of
runes kind of debatable whether I should
do this before I get the uh Diaries done
but H I don't want to do this bear chest
number 21 is a bunch of Bolt racks and a
bunch of chaos
runes uh but yeah nothing great we have
another bear chest coming up here it's
going to be quite a bit of death runes
to be honest that's 300 that's quite a
bit and and chest number 24 something is
a fair bit of runes can't complain okay
we actually got level 54 farming from
that farm run uh which is nice cuz we're
slowly getting our farming levels up
there uh for later in the game when we
have to do diary requirements quests
we'll already have a decently High
farming level on top of that we actually
got 39 rars and one run that's insane
has just some serious luck I got like
seven or eight from each patch all right
we're on to another Barrow chest and a
pretty mediocre War Bo that's Barrow's
chest number
32 h well all right so we're just uh
doing some agility now uh kind of my
doubts whether bar is actually a very
like consistent or good money maker it's
definitely really fun and I definitely
going to do it still but I think I'm
going to hold off on grinding out a ton
of them until I actually have the diary
requirements uh for now we're just going
to do some agility and Al some stuff as
well all right we're actually just about
to hit another agility level uh which
will be pretty sweet that's going to
bring us to 55 uh pretty decent
Milestone there uh we've still saving up
for uh the last piece of our graceful
equipment so hopefully we'll have that
soon okay so we've kind of been
stockpiling a bunch of items just from
doing um barrows and farming and just a
little bit of other random crap as well
uh so we have the two verox plate skirts
H yes I realized I just insta sold this
and uh it was totally accident didn't
even think about what I was doing I just
wanted to get all the stuff sold uh but
I really should have waited but oh well
it's done already uh we got the blood
runes sold we got 370k in blood runes uh
500 65k in death runes now it's kind of
going to be interesting cuz I still have
to recharge my Trident as well as uh use
a little bit of zver scales and stuff on
my blowpipe so there is definitely some
costs here and it's kind of hard to tell
exactly how much money I'm making from
barrows uh obviously I did pretty well
but I got extremely lucky so I'm not
sure how many of these I'm going to do
until maybe I've done the diary or
whatever anyway let's hit collect and
6.2 mil not bad so I think we like to
try the uh gnome restaurant uh
moneymaking method and you do require a
bit of the troll quest line done uh so
we're going to start off with the death
plateau and move on to troll stronghold
uh and eventually we do want the farming
patch as well so we kind let to get this
started all right we're just talking to
Harold uh we have to get him drunk I
think uh this Quest you do some gambling
in which is kind of cool all right so
we're just finishing up the quest uh
death Plateau gives you access to the
climbing boots which are not really
useful at this point uh oh wait sorry
steel Claws and 3,000 attack experience
uh not too bad all right uh next up
we're going to be doing a troll
stronghold uh which gives you access to
the climbing boots I think I don't even
know I haven't I don't even know if I've
ever done troll troll stronghold uh but
we're going to go get the quest started
all right we got to fight this Derpy
looking troll here with the buck teas
I'm pretty sure you can just safe spot
it over here uh well the guy told me so
I didn't really figure this out on my
own uh but blowpipe will make short work
of this dude all right there we go we
have access to law Talisman and uh one
Quest point but more importantly we can
start Edgar's ruse uh which we need for
the trollheim teleport all right so
we've uh started the Edgar's ruse Quest
and this is my favorite part uh I have a
quest for you what is it you must bring
me cooked
human um so yeah we'll have to go get
that for him don't remember how you go
about doing this but I really hope uh
you don't do the obvious options okay no
we're good uh we're actually stealing a
parrot which we have now gotten
drunk whatever I don't really question
this too much but yeah we H gave the
parrot some vodka and we're going to
move on all right and now we have to
sneak through this which is kind of
reminiscent of a Pokemon
or Bomberman or something I don't know
uh so hopefully we can actually get this
quickly cuz we did not bring much
food oh God all right we're just
finishing up Edgar's ruse and there's
11k herblore experience and access to
the trollheim teleport which will be
very nice uh for the restaurant mini
game but also just in general I don't
think I've actually ever had this
teleport spell before so I'm pretty
excited okay and the last requirement
for The Gnome restaurant uh mini game is
actually 42 cooking so we can make all
the drinks and all the uh snacks I guess
you'd call them um so in the back I
think my cooking levels will just roll
uh cuz I don't know it's people know how
to cook already it's not going to take
very long um but so I thought maybe
explain what I'm kind of going for a
little better so the gnome restaurant is
a mini game we do in The Gnome
stronghold apparently you can make up
towards of 1.2 1 mil an hour uh and
these mainly come from The Gnome scarves
you can get which were worth 800k as
well as the known balls which are worth
200k each um it's pretty low Quest
requirement to be honest like troll
stronghold is not even required it's
just one of the people you deliver to uh
and I just wanted to make sure
everything was unlocked uh but yeah
really all you need is afford to2
cooking and uh I guess you may have have
to do Grand Tree or something uh but
yeah we're going to see how well this
works it's a little confusing so we're
going to do some testing and probably
come back with some serious progress in
the next episode uh but for now I'm
pretty excited to try it never done this
before at all and uh yeah we're just
going to finish leveling up our cooking
and then we'll go give it a shot okay
there is another cooking level that is
going to be 35 cooking only seven more
levels uh till we can uh do the
gnome garden gnome restaurant Nome
stronghold whatever you know what I'm
talking about seven more levels and uh
we can cook tuna well that is a lot of
blue feathers thank you 311 for your
generous donation of 72 , 213 blue
feathers uh it's going to a good cause H
nice score
man all right so back to the cooking
mini grind we're actually just supposed
to hit 42 cooking we just uh finished it
up with tuna did not take that long at
all some interesting chatter going on
here at the Rogues Den fireplace but uh
there we go we're going to go give gnome
restaurant a try uh for the very first
time this is really [__] confusing I
really hope there's a Wiki for this this
cuz this will be very challenging uh
it's not like that difficult but there's
a bunch of different ingredients
different meals uh I'm sure you'll catch
on quickly but uh we're going to have to
learn this uh in the beginning which
might have a bit of a learning
curve all right guys so just to show you
exactly what I'm doing here we're going
to do a example order uh so we're in the
top level the Grand Tree we're over on
the West Side uh once you do the
introductory uh mini Quest thing you can
talk to uh John Jor see I'm ready to
take another order edge of the world is
no limit for me which basically means
you're doing the hard deliveries uh so
now we KN know Captain nto wants a
wizard blizzard okay so now we've
started the timer uh we have 11 minutes
to go deliver the uh product for that
person so what we need for the wizard
blizzard is we need some vodka gin a
lemon and an orange which it doesn't
actually look like they sell vodka here
so that's a little annoying so sadly we
actually had to buy the ingredients on
the grind exchange so once you have
everything you uh make the cocktail and
then uh we need to serve it with oh [__]
me we need to serve it with something on
top I think as well what what what are
we missing here yeah Pineapple Chunk oh
my sweet
Jesus
Pineapple Chunk let's buy [__]
pineapple
chunks am I missing anything else come
on there we go got the wizard blizzard
that took way too long now we have to go
under the White Wolf Mountain to find uh
ninto or whatever his name was uh oh
that was a wrong place we're just
killing it right now uh so obviously the
best call would probably be to stockpile
all of these required items in your bank
in the beginning uh possibly even
stockpile of the unfinished products I
think might be be the quickest way to do
this uh cuz obviously this is very
inefficient I'm just trying to figure it
out though uh and we'll get there
eventually
uhoh
what no let me
buy so it turns out I need to do fishing
contest which is unfortunate cuz this is
one of the two guys actually hands out
the gnome scarf which is worth 800
okay so obviously I have no clue what
the hell I'm doing so I think the good
call here is for me to just learn this
do any of the quests that are required
and maybe get back to you guys all right
guys so we have been messing around a
little bit with the gnome restaurant
I've done a couple orders uh and uh we
have successfully gotten some tips uh
that being said I think we're going to
leave the bulk of this for the next
episode I'd rather uh take the time to
learn it properly and then show you guys
how to do it properly at first because
it is kind of confusing there's no point
of you just following me doing it wrong
and then you know there it just get
confusing for everyone uh so that being
said I think that's where we're going to
end the episode for today uh if you are
extremely hyped to see a guide regarding
the gnome restaurant and how you could
possibly be making 1 mil an hour roughly
from this uh with some pretty low
requirements toss this video a like I'll
know to work on that right away and
always thanks for watching guys and I
hope I'll see you in the next episode